où
s'il est ma vérité bien oui dans la
première émission de jeudi cinéma nous
avions essayé de faire un parallèle vous
le savez entre un gag du film de jacques
tati mon oncle et les réactions des gens
de la rue filmée par une caméra cachée
savait pas mal marché d'ailleurs alors
là nous aurions bien voulu pour leur
faire le gag du film de corneau le gars
qu'on voit au début du film où la
voiture vous savez se déglingue au
moindre choc
malheureusement antennes de nous n'avons
pas les moyens de faire un gag aussi
somptueux alors nous sommes contentés de
deux trucs et simplement un taxi un faux
taxi qui est conduit par jacques legras
et dont toutes les poignées de porte
ce reste dans la main quand on tire
dessus alors quelles vont être les
réactions des gens de la rue avec ce
taxi un peu spéciale de monsieur jacques
legras regardez vous allez va
des fêtes oui je vois je sais pas ce qui
se passe à l' arrivée c'est la foi qui
doit être sympa qu'elle doit coincé
alors maintenant on va plutôt rire il va
passer par d'autres tirs ici
avant la passe est trop tôt pour l'autre
côté vous m'avez vous m'avez arracher
les trois sets costaud heureusement je
vous expliquerai l'édifice abrite et
bien non les images on va t'aider à la
batterie si vous voulez ouvrir la porte
là je vais avoir un effet ça fait de doc
et les costauds demander d'ici là
mathieu voyez rien s'était laissé aller
comme ça il fallait la prendre avec
osamu cette foutue c'est sûr si vous
savez vous où va sa feria pattani
ouvrait la porte normal on va nombre et
celle ci l'a plutôt et n'oubliez alors
vous n'ouvrez celle là là merci à ma
caisse qui se passe alors des composites
ou abel tiennent elles tiennent matin là
où elles sont arrachés ya pas de montre
vie là bas vous allécher pour soi
c'était c'était pour vous cette voiture
sepsi enfin oui et non ça c'était pour
aujourd'hui cinéma vous savez je vis
cinéma oui oui pas ouvrir ou vraie celle
ci il avait arraché
vous l'avez arraché la pole et n'a rien
fait du tout mais si elles sont davis
est monté pendant mon enfance j'ai
besoin de mecs à verrières aussi vous
avez vous avez ri mais la voiture là moi
j'ai pas abîmer vous qu'est ce que vous
avez à la mère avait aussi s'attend à
pouvoir vous l'avez remarqué deux
catégories chez les clients de jacques
legras
tout d'abord les gens très honnête qu'il
rende immédiatement la poignée à son
propriétaire
ça mettrait le regarder je vous la donne
oui merci oui et cassel presse que vous
allez avenue wagram baba monte à côté de
moi alors c'est bien les points c'est
deuxième catégorie les bricoleurs
section si las vegas est aussi celle là
alors moi je les casser bah oui moi je
les casser
en effet le matériel et moi je venais à
côté de moi ça fait rien
ah bon vous présente tellement costaud
on est dedans